because i don't really have a problem
trying harder i have a problem letting
things go so oh well helps me let things
go
so you're competitive
well
obviously we raced against each other
you're ultra competitive and ultra
competitive and you get super sonic
pissed off when you when when things
don't go
danica's way that's i like that the most
about you because i like getting pissed
off when things don't go my way
it feels better it does yeah it's an
expression of what's cooped up inside
you just gotta let it out when was the
time that you feel like you let it out
the most and paid the biggest
consequence you know probably the only
time that i ever really let myself go
that i didn't like i didn't care like i
was so pissed off i didn't even know my
helmet was on put it that way and with
ryan newman after the race because
honestly it scared the crap out of me we
got together in a racetrack and things
happen right well
at charlotte
and i am literally after the race it's
over and i'm i'm taking my belts off
like i didn't even have seat belts on
and he hit me
and it spun me head on into the wall i
mean i wasn't going 180 miles an hour
anymore but i was still running probably
70 you know and and smoked the wall and
spun back around and i was it like
literally didn't even have my my
anything on
dude i lost it i i went completely
out of my mind and and last next thing i
know i'm i'm literally some
some crew guy has a hold of me and it's
got me clear off my feet and i was like
rock em sock em to ryan newman through
through his window now like i didn't
even know what was going on i was so mad
that it was you know that's that's
racing that's competition right
that's the moment though you asked the
question that's the yeah got away from
me what was the one cause i love a good
fight and i love i love it and when like
when there's a red flag and you're still
on track and there's a fight that breaks
out you know because the crowd gets
excited and the one i'm thinking of that
has an awesome clip that's turned into a
total like meme gift for you is i think
it was phoenix well i know it was
phoenix and you running through the from
the from pit lane through the garage
were you chasing
jeff down jeff gordon yeah my
counterpart and now you work together
what the hell
what happened well the first day back on
the job was a little bit awkward let's
just go ahead and say that but
we had to get past our differences but
there was a lot of differences right
there
but
at the end of the day we both knew that
that was going to be fine but that was
what did he do to you he wrecked me now
i he calls it retaliation i call it it
was it was that aggravation and and you
know he he wrecked me after the actual
it was during the race
it was down to the crunch time in the in
the playoffs and we were racing for a
championship and
you know that was the next to last race
so we were down to
a lot of money on the line a lot of
business you know there so uh that one
was that one stung a little bit that one
hit the old pocket book and when that
happens that's a whole nother level of
pissed offness is that a word was that
is that what makes you the most pissed
off the funniest part about that story
was
we were supposed to leave there things
were good
we were flying to l.a to uh
to blake shelton's house
and he was uh
who's we you and jeff no me and laura my
wife laura yep awesome awesome
we're flying to l.a
and we're going to go to the voice it's
her first time she's a huge john levine
day she wanted to meet him right so
really wasn't about any of us it was
about that we get there blake wants
nothing because he's a huge smart ass
like i am he doesn't care about anything
other than what happened on the race you
know let's let's by the time we land in
l.a he is on a twitter war with all of
the universe
all jeff gordon fans it's like little
video clint's fan base and jeff gordon's
fan base it's been in a sport for 50
years you know it's like he is in a
fight with all of them including ingrid
his wife i'm like
what are you doing no stop
so
that happened we end up getting through
that and that was probably the most fun
thing about it it was that night
afterwards is seeing how much
satisfaction and enjoyment blake got out
of the fact that i got wrecked on that
racetrack
um
yeah
yeah yeah it's good to have friends in
high places
it wasn't that was a pretty low place
for me right there i could tell you that
you were low but blake you talk about
your you know fan base and jeff's and
then blake's see i don't see that i see
him being
an oklahoma boy i don't see this la guy
that everybody else sees i see the
redneck from oklahoma but he kind of but
he lives in l.a part of the time right
yeah
yeah
kind of
sure i don't like that blake la blake is
it's different blake l.a bike is is
is you know
hair done and and weird clothes on i
like camouflage blake that's that's the
blake i like camo blake do you find that
do you find the the clothes that you'd
like to that you normally see blake in
down at uh what's your favorite store
that you go to every time you're home
true blue blue shirt something
there you go how what did you did you
ruined my profile how did you remember
bluestone that is the best store ever
ever it can fix anything but a broken
heart in the moon i'm telling you right
now if it can be fixed
it's going to happen at bluestone
because there's everything from what to
what there it's got a wall of wranglers
500 feet long
so you got close it's got a bootleg it's
got work gloves it's got cattle shoots
it's got feed it has hydraulic oil like
bolt bend galore anything that you need
to fix anything dana because see that
that picture on the wall you hung it
with blue stem parts and pieces that
that behind you was done at blue stiff
that i'm telling you the gamut whether
it's danican scottsdale arizona or
[ __ ] clint and emporia kansas i'm
telling you it can be fixed it sounds
like you could fix a broken heart there
though if they sell beer and fishing
rods and guns
seems like you could just sort of take
that out there into the world and and
get better it's a great point because my
heart does feel better every time i go
there just makes me feel better about
myself it doesn't matter how bad a day
it can be fixed at bluestem go blow four
or five hundred dollars at bluestem the
day is fixed where do you get all this
humor from clint i really want to know
let's unpack your childhood we're going
to go going to unpack my childhood yeah
i feel like it's in there somewhere i
thought this was a podcast not a
psychiatry you know i don't know
it's both you won't know the difference
man i don't know i i grew up as a middle
child um you know the biggest thing with
our family is no different probably than
yours we raced non-stop we didn't
sometimes do anything else you know we
tried to do the
you know stick and ball stuff my brother
played some basketball um
we i went to football i guess at camp
the first day is that camp before you
know school starts with all my my big
corn fed buddies go into football camp
i'm thinking man i want my pads i want
my helmet i mean i'm ready to go i'm
gonna be a football player right
probably yeah you're not big enough to
be an offensive lineman
this is my story you asked the question
i'm telling you
so so here i am thinking i'm gonna have
my own helmet right can i have pads i'm
gonna be the man the coach and i will
never forget this this is my football
career in one day nutshell story first
thing we do walk in the door and he goes
all right boys run to mcdonald's and
give me a a
a big mac and come back i'm like
you mean
the mcdonald's in town
it was six miles into town he made the
football team run run
to get him a sandwich at mcdonald's and
back
oh clint didn't have that in him i was
like man this ain't for me no helmet no
pads and running nah nah nah nah i'm
gonna go back to uh to race and
motorcycles so that was my football
career um tried basketball still not
tall enough you know so it was
motorcycles for us we actually my dad
owned a towing service and tony reynolds
a guy that worked for him
um back in you know the day raced
motorcycles he had a practice track
behind my father's
shop in his towing business
and we used to go back there i mean
little little i remember watching tony
ride you know his motorcycles back there
i'm talking before pw 50s so santa claus
naturally after we were watching tony
rides here comes
you know
santa claus brings us pw50 which is a
tiny little bike right it's like a
little
everybody's introduction fit you know 50
motorcycle forever i mean my god it's
things still exist and the part number
is exactly the same from 1981 that's how
good of a problem
oh my god
but there are people listening that are
probably living somewhere like
california or you know new york and they
don't know well they got to use electric
ones now i don't even think they allow
anything gasoline out there anymore you
can't even have a gasoline lawnmower in
california anymore what kind of fun is
that
zero i know i hope they run out of
battery use a generator to start it
i'll loan them one so anyway here we go
we're going racing we have a tractor
tire that does everybody full of sand
that was our sand pit where we're old
enough now that we have motorcycles
there's no reason for a sand pit anymore
we built a ramp over the the tractor
tire
the rest is history man we were off
motorcycle racing and and having a blast
doing it as a family like i was saying
and traveling all over the place the one
thing that was instilled in us from an
early age and you don't know it until
you get older is is the work ethic that
your parents put forth for you to have
this opportunity in your career
and it happened for me you know once i
had kids i look back now that cash is
racing late uh go-carts and i'm like dad
what in the hell were you thinking
i mean we were racing 13 hours away in
lake whitney texas on a sunday afternoon
just an afternoon race just a summer
shootout race every single weekend 13
hours away we would wake up in grade
school parking lot walk straight into
the the school and go to school he drove
all night long all by himself did it
every single week your dad drove then
right he was strong
what do you live off of because i'll
tell you what my dad lived off of
because he did something similar too
what did he take what did he eat or
drink to stay alive for those two my dad
always ran you know he had a towing
service that's 24 hours seven days a
week doesn't matter if that phone ring i
honestly just think
he
conditioned himself to do that like he
literally would drink some coffee every
now and then but nothing usually nothing
just wow well my dad was just on pure
crack he was on mountain dew mountain
dew and sweet darts
i'm telling you like he
it was a beast when it came to that like
you know when we grew up we had you know
as people had phones in your house
remember those remember that phone
number
right yeah i bet yours was long go
hiding around the corner how long ago
did
of course yeah i had so many boyfriends
i'd have totally have i have a long cord
boyfriend called you're on 100 foot cord
out in the backyard in a shed
from the living room
ah
so we
saying i love you no i love you i love
you more i love you more i love you the
most i love you infinity those kind of
conversations when you're like you know
12. yeah i didn't have those we were
racing so anyway
we had a line in our in our house that
was line one was home and it had a
different ring line two ring you knew
what that meant
as soon as you heard that in the middle
of the night you'd hear dad stomping
down the hallway going to toe some drunk
out of the ditch at 3 o'clock in the
morning and
probably wasn't even going to get paid
like he always did that so that work
ethic
was was there from the beginning for us
and and honestly that's what i think
kind of what what made us who we are you
know but but you asked me why i guess a
sense of humor just being on the road
having nothing else to do then just pick
on one another you know when my old man
and i are together
everybody's like
what the hell is going on do you guys
hate each other you're like
what are you talking about this is our
love language like you you guys are
cussing each other and
but he hasn't left yet you're like
that's just kind of the way we we i
don't know that's how it works
so
we've we've always had a lot of fun and
it always you know usually was going up
and down the roads you know racing and
so many stories you know like
my older brother let me tell you a funny
story yeah i should probably shouldn't
even be here so my brother was had his
learner's permit which i think in kansas
you could get at 14
right
so
the old man was working a truck rack the
night before here we are headed back
down to texas
and we had a winnebago now we're big
time right we had like time three i
think it was a little we had a van
yeah chieftain 33 winnebago
we were i tell you how big a deal we
were we were in the back this old girl
had not one bed you know it had two like
little single double whatever they are
in the back but we were playing excite
bike i will never forget this the day i
died me and my buddy were playing excite
bike remember that game pretty much
nintendo excitebike are you kidding me i
played track and field in duck hunt i
didn't play
side by side it's cool that's the excite
bike excite bike
it sounds good
for a boy who loves bikes anyway we're
racing motorcycles we're playing side
bike going down the highway dad falls
asleep lets andy drive 14 years old
[Music]
annie's gets cruz sat in the old
winnebago here we are next thing i know
like you're jumping jumps and
it wasn't the motorcycle jumping anymore
it's the winnebago jumping we go
barreling down through the median boom
boom boom
back up on the top the refrigerator
flies open a whole bowl of chili mom
made forest flies out of the
refrigerator all over the floor broke
the glass pot
that's fine i tell you how hard we hit
it true dad out of the passenger seat on
the floor he looks up there's headlights
coming so he freaks out grabs a hole the
wheel and pulls the thing so here we are
bounce through the ditch and i mean
jumping through the ditch it gets calm
right it's like all right i i think
everything's fine next thing i know nope
wasn't enough we're on the wrong side of
the road dad pulls the wheel
back over the ditch we go all the way
through the whoops like we just went
through hell and back we get back on the
right side of the road and by this time
all of us are on the ground the tv and
everything's off excite bike's gone
we're like what in the hell just
happened my buddy go running up front
dad is on his knees he is on his knees
driving the motor home andy is freaked
out with his eyes this big
finally get this thing stopped my
brother freaks out takes berlin out
right out the door and we're running now
we're like the clamp it's out on the
side of the highway
running from my dad
like clear over by the fence on the on
the highway like
what what happened
so andy fell asleep we had deal
winnebago was ghost riding is what i'm
trying to tell you
so then we had like a family huddle
right so what do we do do we turn around
we're freaked out we're scared
everybody's scared but everybody's okay
you know we go back and check the the
load out in the trailer bikes are fine
nothing's really crazy there so dad's
like well you boys want to go racing
kept going baby
oh my god that is spectacular no you
guys ever have any wild stories on the
road i mean there's no food left but go
racing why not chilly and by the way a
hell of a mess
in a refrigerator in a motor home just
for that very reason
yeah that sounds like it'd be an
absolute awful job that i'm sure you
boys had to do
do i have crazy stories like that no
like i don't my sister and i just
cuddled in the back of the
truck we at first dad had a truck with a
little extender cab on the back
and then we got a van so the extender
cab was either way too hot or way too
cold and brooke and i would lay up there
and sleep a lot and then um and then we
got a van and we called it the fun van
because all the fun's inside
and uh it had an electric back back
bench that laid down to a bed it was
electric pretty cool
and there's a tv in the middle so we
could watch movies and headsets on each
side i mean it was a minute so that's
like a conversion van
well it was a real van i mean it was one
of those giant electric couch that's
like that's a high-end deal well it
wasn't a winnebago though well i mean
this is true this is true
so no we just cuddled and and and you
know dad dad's fiery so sometimes there
was some crying going on after races but